you talk about the most exciting home
run for you being in 57 now
the home run where you uh broke babe
ruth's record
uh that was not a happy experience for
you or not completely happy
well i had some trouble i had some
moments you know in 57 and
56 and 57 there were some times when
when things just wasn't going right for
me
it was some tough moments not only for
me but it was tough
uh for my kids right the kids i had a
daughter in college at fish university
at the time
and she couldn't they wouldn't allow her
to get out of
to do some things that she wanted to do
but other than that um
uh the babe ruth experience it was
breaking that record it wasn't uh
you know the experience you said was
marred to some degree because of the way
that that uh
people reacted to yeah because of all
the letters that i received you know i
received over
all 150 some odd thousand letters that i
received that year
people were was against me breaking the
record but right
you know as i said so many times you
know that's been you know it's going on
20 years now
in fact in in april it would be 20 years
since i hit that home run
right and it just doesn't seem like it
was that long
but uh some great things have happened
since then well do you think if you
do you think if you had made made the
accomplishment uh
that you made in 74 if you made that
today do you think things would be
different
i don't know i think that uh i think
that things would be a little different
but i
i have some i really don't it's kind of
hard for me to say you know it's really
it's kind of tough because you know you
have to remember that that was
20 20 years ago and some of the things i
was going through
people just wasn't really was not
in tune with and you know blacks had
just gotten into baseball and some
things that was happening
that uh people would not have not
adjusted their life yeah you'd like to
think there's been
a lot of progress i would like to think
that's been some progress um now
before uh we we have to wrap it before
we do i just want to mention the big
brother big sister program that
you're working on now oh that's a good
program i've been associated with them
now for
for over eight years and we've raised uh
somewhere in the neighborhood of eight
million dollars
that's terrific all right okay thank you
very much for being here